ende viele einschränkungen das kabinett
ebnet den weg um die grundrechte von
geimpften weniger zu beschneiden von
deutschland bis paraguay dank
internationale zusammenarbeit gelingt es
ermittlern eine große kinderporno
plattform im darknet zu sprengen und
neues von den stars fehlanzeige englands
profifußballer boykottieren social media
aus protest gegen rassismus im netz
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara vinken abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sport in unserer familie
jetzt soll es ganz flott gehen mit
lockerungen für corona geimpfte und
genesene heute hat das kabinette
entsprechenden verordnung zugestimmt
im idealfall so gesundheitsminister
sparen wird sie noch diese woche von
bundestag und bundesrat beschlossen
danach darf er vollständig geimpft oder
genesen ist nachts unterwegs seien trotz
ausgangs beschränkungen sich mit weniger
einschränkungen mit anderen treffen und
ohne test beispielsweise läden museen
oder auch friseure besuchen
david gebhard berichtet erst impfen dann
feiern so verheißt ist die aufschrift an
einer berliner konzerthalle
doch das ist noch zukunftsmusik in ihrem
verordnungsentwurf geht es der
bundesregierung zunächst um drängendere
lockerung für geimpfte und genießen der
gesundheitsminister verspricht dass wir
jetzt auch sehr schnell ins wort für
vollständig geimpft
nicht nur eine gleichstellung mit
tagesaktuell getesteten für bestimmte
lebensbereiche vornehmen wollen sondern
vor allem auch keine beschränkung wie
kontakt oder ausgangs beschränkungen
mehr auferlegt wissen wollen einigkeit
heute im corona kabinett auch
spd-vizekanzler scholz will schnelle
lockerungen für geimpfte und genießen
die derzeit vor allem ältere betreffen
und verweist im zdf was nun interview
auf endlich steigende impfzahlen wir
sind schon sehr sehr weit gekommen das
geht jetzt mit millionen schritten
weiter nach vorne und deshalb werden
auch die jüngeren und die studierenden
dran kommt derweil meldet das lka etwa
23,5 millionen erstimpfungen das
entspricht 28,2 prozent der bevölkerung
zweimal geimpft und damit vollständig
geschützt sind mehr als 6,6 millionen
menschen und damit genau 8 prozent die
geplanten lockerungen betreffen damit
zunächst nur eine minderheit und gehen
der fdp nicht weit genug
wir sind uns sicher dass eine öffnung
von kultur und sportstätten für geimpfte
und genesen in vielen bereichen
möglich ist vor allen dingen kann die
außengastronomie mit schutz konzepten
geöffnet werden kritik auch am fehlenden
digitalen impfpass als nachweis
ungeplante lockerungen wahrnehmen zu
können würde zunächst das gelbe im buch
die ihnen oder eine ausgedruckte
bescheinigung besonders fälschungssicher
ist das alles nicht da wird man mit
nichts besseres haben müssen wir damit
wohl oder übel arbeiten macht natürlich
die große frage auf wie kann es sein im
jahre 2021 dass deutschland mit dieser
zettelwirtschaft unterwegs ist die
verordnung zu erleichterungen für
geimpfte soll möglichst noch in dieser
woche auf den weg gebracht werden
unter einbeziehung von bundestag und
bundesrat
was nun olaf scholz das ganze gespräch
mit dem finanzminister und spd
kanzlerkandidaten sehen sie direkt nach
und wer sollte möglichst schnell geimpft
werden immer deutlicher zeigt sich dass
menschen in sozialen brennpunkten zu den
besonders gefährdeten gehören
in köln etwa traf das virus ärmere
zeitweise rund zehn mal so oft wie die
bewohner wohlhabender viertel
gründe gibt es viele wohnen auf engstem
raum etwa oder menschen die auf busse
und bahnen angewiesen sind ab heute
kommen die impf teams zu ihnen
dominik moser die vorbereitungen laufen
vor und im infobus der feuerwehr
es dauert noch bis es los gehen kann
draußen bereits eine lange schlange der
infos ist in köln chorweiler heute
nachmittag die renner damals mir
geschrieben
sie schrieb trägt dass das impfangebot
da ist und auch ab 16 und dann habe ich
gesagt mach ich habe uns vor ohne sein
dass schwerin ich wollte lassen spritzen
wir sind gerade zufällig vorbeigekommen
haben wir gesehen dass das hier
aufgestellt wurden habe ich gesagt okay
nimm doch mal schnell war sonst muss ich
ja auch genauso wie alle anderen warten
750.000 moderner gibt es heute impfdosen
die niemandem weggenommen werden sondern
die es zusätzlich vom land gibt das zu
betonen es den organisatoren wichtig
dass impfen im brennpunkt soll allen
zugute kommen das ziel ist damit
menschen die erhöhten oder hohem
infektionsrisiko ausgesetzt sind
aufgrund der lebenssituation impfangebot
zu machen um eben dann in der
verlängerung unsere gesundheitssysteme
dann natürlich auch vor belastungen
stück weit zu schützen
die inzidenz in chorweiler liegt bei
über 500 auch weil hier etliche menschen
leben die kaum deutsch sprechen und
schlecht informiert sind die aktion
heute soll auch aufklären dass wir halt
gerne möchten ist dass wir wirklich die
leute in den risikosituationen erreichen
das sind aber teilweise gerade die die
ihre situation gar nicht als risiko oft
empfinden so dass hier das impfen ist
ein baustein aber das bewusstmachen die
information
das ist glaube ich noch ein viel
wichtigerer baustein in chorweiler
kommen die in dosen nun zu den menschen
damit es vorangeht da wo es besonders
nötig ist die korona waren app des
bundes bekommt eine weitere funktion in
der neuen version werden auch ergebnisse
von schnelltests angezeigt damit können
anwender nach einem schnelltest den
qr-code einscannen kurze zeit später
erhalten sie in der app das testresultat
zum beispiel zur vorlage beim friseur
oder beim einkaufen
das update soll spätestens morgen zur
verfügung stehen
seit zehn tagen ist die bundes notbremse
in kraft und sie hilft sagt der verband
der intensiv und notfallmedizin die
maßnahmen plus die im fortschritte
würden die lage auf den
intensivstationen
schon in einer woche könnte die zahl der
patienten dort senken und auch die zahl
der neuinfektionen geht weiter zurück
das robert koch institut meldet 9160
neue fälle binnen 24 stunden das sind
2747 weniger als am vergangenen montag
84 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents liegt bei 146,9 wie immer
nach dem wochenende sind die gemeldeten
zahlen unvollständig weitere zahlen zu
corona finden sie in der zdf- heute- app
darin auch ein vergleich zwischen
deutschland großbritannien und schweden
und was die unterschiedlichen maßnahmen
dieser länder jeweils gebracht haben
das oktoberfest größtes volksfest der
welt fällt auch in diesem jahr aus
bisher wiesen geht nicht sagte münchens
oberbürgermeister reiter das oktoberfest
funktionieren nicht mit einschränkungen
und es sei nicht absehbar wie sich die
infektionszahlen entwickeln
üblicherweise kommen mehr als sechs
millionen menschen aus aller welt zur
wiesn nach münchen
wie wichtig die altenpflege wie wichtig
eine angemessene entlohnung für
pflegekräfte ist das hat die politik
immer wieder betont aber abgesehen von
einem corona bonus dauerhaft und vor
allem flächendeckend ist wenig passiert
nun machten gleich zwei ministerien
konkrete vorschläge und streiten um den
richtigen weg
britta spiekermann altenpflegekräfte
sollen besser bezahlt werden minimum
nach tarif die minister jens spahn und
hubertus heil liefern sich in dieser
frage einen bettler heute bekräftigt der
arbeitsminister seinen vorstoß die zeit
bringen
es darf keine ausreden geben die
pflegekräfte haben mehr geld verdient
wie viel grips kraft krieg prototype
2100 euro im schnitt
dass es zu wenig es muss deutlich besser
werden der arbeitsminister will das
stationäre pflegeheime und ambulante
anbieter nur dann leistungen aus der
pflegekasse bekommen wenn sie ihre
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter nach
tarif bezahlen
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen zeigte
sich heute überrascht vom vorstoß seines
minister kollegen sie wissen ich habe
schon vor wochen einen konkreten
regelungsvorschlag ein gesetzesvorschlag
vorgelegt wie eine entsprechende
regelhafte tarif bezahlung in der
stationären und ambulanten altenpflege
umgesetzt werden kann
die beiden vorschläge erinnern sich
sogar sehr
insofern war ich jetzt überrascht seit
mitte märz liegt schwarzarbeit sind wohl
für eine pflegereform vor darin auch
flächendeckende tarife als pflicht für
pflegeanbieter der eigenanteil für
pflegebedürftige soll gedeckelt werden
damit kosten nicht abgewälzt werden
können jens spahn will tempo machen
hubertus heil auch zwei ähnliche
vorschläge einen gemeinsamen weg gehen
das wollen sie ganz bewusst vermeiden
das klingt nach wahlkampf von einer
widerwärtigen plattform spricht hessens
justiz ministerin und davon dass
straftäter sich auch im darknet nicht
sicher fühlen könnten
eine der weltweit größten plattformen
für sexuellen missbrauch von kindern
haben deutsche behörden gesprengt in
internationaler zusammenarbeit vier
deutsche wurden festgenommen einer in
paraguay stefan schlosser hat der geist
funktionierte wie ein marktplatz
verborgen im anonymen darknet die
gehandelte ware bilder und videos von
kindern zumeist jungen darunter
zahlreiche darstellungen schwersten
sexuellen missbrauchs mit mehr als
400.000 mitgliedern gehörte die
plattform zu den größten drei deutsche
männer im alter von 40 bis 58 jahren
sollen die hauptverantwortlichen sein
bei drei der beschuldigten besteht der
dringende tatverdacht als
administratoren auf boys tätig gewesen
zu sein
in dieser funktion sollen sie die
plattform ins leben gerufen haben sollen
die infrastruktur zur verfügung gestellt
haben den server gewartet haben sollen
sich um die mitgliederbetreuung
gekümmert haben ein weiterer 64 jahre
alter mann soll als einer der aktivsten
nutzer allein über 3.500 beiträge
gepostet haben alle befinden sich
zurzeit in u-haft einer der verdächtigen
wurde in paraguay festgenommen
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer
äußerte sich zufrieden dieser
ermittlungserfolg hat eine klare
botschaft wer sich an den schwächsten
vergeht ist nirgendwo sicher
wir ziehen die täter zur rechenschaft
und tun das menschenmögliche um kinder
vor so widerwärtigen verbrechen zu
schützen
die ermittler haben unmengen an daten
sichergestellt die jetzt ausgewertet
werden müssen
jeder der im eigenen missbrauch begangen
hat den dokumentiert die sachen hoch
aber es wird auch vieles bekanntes
material natürlich getauscht und diese
pädokriminelle szene sind auch die
sammler die versuchen möglichst viel
bildmaterial zu bekommen sich
gegenseitig auch anzustarren was du ein
großer ermittlungserfolg die plattform
boys town wurde abgeschaltet aber sie
war nur eine von vielen mehr als 14
monate nach der autor attacke auf den
rosenmontagszug im hessischen volkmarsen
sind die motive völlig unklar
auch heute zum prozessauftakt schweigt
der angeklagte
die staatsanwaltschaft spricht von
mordversuch in 91 fällen viele opfer
unter ihnen zahlreiche kinder erlitten
schwere verletzungen
demnach war der 30-jährige angeklagte
absichtlich mit seinem auto in den umzug
und die zuschauer gerast schneller als
50 stundenkilometer 31 verhandlungstage
sind angesetzt
journalisten leben in weiten teilen der
welt gefährlich darauf weist jedes jahr
der internationale tag der
pressefreiheit hin
auf der rangliste von reporter ohne
grenzen sind die skandinavischen länder
vorbildlich deutschland liegt auf platz
13 auch bei uns nehmen die angriffe auf
kolleginnen und kollegen zu noch sehr
viel riskanter ist das journalistische
arbeiten allerdings in ländern wie
russland ran 150 von dort berichtet
christian sam alexis taylor hat gemacht
was reporter für gewöhnlich tun
rausgehen und berichten auf der letzten
demonstration für alexej nawalny vor
zwei wochen war der reporter für den
unabhängigen sender tv dort unterwegs
klar zu erkennen mit presse weste ein
paar tage später aber klingelt die
polizei morgens an seiner wohnungstür
der vorwurf teilnahme an nicht
genehmigten protesten
all diese handlung nicht nur gegen meine
person sondern auch gegen kollegen
anderer medien zielen offensichtlich
darauf ab um uns und anderen zu zeigen
dass man unsere arbeit verfolgt
man kann das als anzeichen sehen dass
die daumenschrauben von allen seiten
angezogen werden alexej musste mit aufs
revier zwei stunden und etliche
erklärungen später ließen sie den
reporter wieder gehen journalistin oder
journalist seien in russland das war
noch nie leicht auf ist es auch
gefährlich
der kreml kontrolliert die
medienlandschaft weitgehend letzte woche
wurde das internetportal medusa als
sogenannter ausländische agent
eingestuft das heißt jeder artikel muss
mit dem agenten status markiert sein
werbekunden springen reihenweise ab das
medium hofft auf spenden um zu überleben
solidarität kommt von anderen
unabhängigen medien also von den wenigen
die es überhaupt noch gibt
wir unterstützen uns auf jegliche art
und weise aber wir sehen dass es in
dieser schlacht gegen das böse nur
geringe chancen gibt zu gewinnen der
druck auf die opposition auf
menschenrechtsorganisationen auf anwälte
und freie medien im jahr der
parlamentswahl in russland wächst
alexej gordejew und andere mutige
journalistinnen und journalisten machen
trotzdem weiter
rassismus hat sich im fußball von den
tribünen in den stadien in die sozialen
netzwerke verlagern
einige spieler werden im netz mit hass
und beleidigungen überschüttet in
england setzen die vereine jetzt ein
deutliches zeichen aus protest
boykottieren sie vier tage lang die
sozialen plattformen und ernten
international applaus aus london andreas
stamm vier tage funkstille
die social media accounts der englischen
profi clubs sind verstummt andere
sportverbände im land haben sich dem
protest gegen rassismus hass und hetze
angeschlossen sponsoren fifa uefa oder
etwa formel-1-weltmeister lewis hamilton
genug sei genug wenn ein gestandener
spieler wie endres townsend nach dem
spiel aus angst nicht mehr aufs handy
schaut unser budget eine warnung an
diese firmen dass wir den hass nicht
mehr hinnehmen passiert dann immer noch
nichts werden vereine spieler und
werbepartner über härtere maßnahmen
nachdenken facebook instagram twitter
und co verteidigen sich auch mit dem
englischen fußball
arbeite man schon länger gemeinsam an
lösungen letzte woche bekannt gegeben
dass wir ein neues eine neue funktion
einführen mit denen sich betroffene die
hass und beleidigende nachrichten hinten
direktnachrichten erhalten wie sie sich
davor schützen können und müssen wir
auch noch besser werden und noch mehr
machen das sieht auch die britische
regierung so ein geplantes gesetz sieht
millionenstrafen vor für firmen die etwa
rassismus nicht wirkungsvoller
unterbinden
könig fußball setzt dagegen auf
marktmacht an spieltagen generieren
millionen klicks für die social media
giganten millionen an werbeeinnahmen
ich freue mich darüber dass wir
gemeinsam ein zeichen setzen so viel
macht nutzen wie fußball als ein teil
oder auch die gesellschaft insgesamt hat
und zwar jetzt in der nacht endet der
boykott der kampf geht weiter und immer
deutlicher wird zeichen allein reichen
englands fußball nicht mehr
man will taten sehen ein ende von hass
und hetze im netz haben nicht bringt was
ja damit sind wir beim deutschen fußball
und einem weiteren trainerwechsel beim
zweitligisten hsv daniel jun geht und
eine hamburger fußball ikone übernimmt
nachwuchsdirektor horst hrubesch soll
den tabellendritten doch noch zum
bundesliga aufstieg führen
ganze drei spieltage bleiben dafür seit
kurzem ist er 70 trainer wollte er
längst nicht mehr sein doch nach fünf
spielen ohne sieg war auch ihm als
nachwuchschef beim hsv klar dass sein
verein einen aufstiegs retter braucht es
nicht mehr viel zeit aber ich glaube es
schafft das sehr gut auch durch seine
positive h durch seine überzeugung in
die dinge der tod nicht zu viel
nachzudenken sondern einfach zu machen
und das ist das was wir jetzt benötigen
als 22 hsv cheftrainer der letzten 14
jahre soll er nur bis zum saisonende
bleiben mit geringer aussicht auf erfolg
denn der tabellen vierte holstein kiel
kann mit den punkten aus drei
nachholspielen leicht vorbei ziehen dann
schaffen sie den aufstieg hier auch mit
hrubesch aus eigener kraft nicht mehr
wegen der dfb internen querelen hatten
die regional und landesverbände
präsident keller und generalsekretär
kurt jooss gestern das vertrauen
entzogen
von keller bislang keine reaktion kurz
muss teilte heute mit er stünde so wird
nicht für gespräche zu konstruktiven
lösungen zur verfügung dies betreffe
auch seine funktion als generalsekretär
140 deutsche meistertitel in 18
sportarten an vier tagen an rhein ruhr
und spree das sind die finales zum
zweiten mal ein hauch von olympia vor
olympia heute wurde das projekt
vorgestellt
die beiden länderchefs sind schon mal in
form vier tage ganz großer sport in der
metropolregion rhein ruhr und in berlin
vom bogensport betonen ein multi sport
ereignis mehr als 25 stunden live
übertragung bei ard und zdf kanals
werden natürlich der auftakt zu einem
riesen sportsommer wir freuen uns drauf
und ich glaube wir werden den pandemie
sommer auf diese art und weise auch
jedenfalls ein bisschen fröhlicher
staaten als die letzten wochen verlaufen
sind mit dabei die stars der szene
fokussiert auf die deutsche
meisterschaft
ich freue mich einfach wieder ein
wettkampf machen zu dürfen ganz wichtig
sind diese wechsel abläufe also wir
trainieren das schon aber im wettkampf
mit der aufregung mit dem druck ist es
dann noch mal was anderes und dafür sind
die finales doch dann ganz wichtig noch
mal die wettbewerbe geplant erst einmal
ohne zuschauer
berlin allerdings hofft ball verbesserte
infektions lage durchaus auf publikum
vorsichtiger optimismus in der atomkrise
wir freuen uns auch darauf oder
unbedingt das wetter freuen uns er nicht
braucht es wird turbulent ein sturm
erreicht deutschland für die nacht warm
der deutsche wetterdienst vor orkanböen
in den höhenlagen des schwarzwalds
details hat gleich aus dem tertiär an
dem was freut sich auf sie im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn und ab
morgen dann hier um 19 uhr
hier geht es weiter mit was nun herr
scholz ich danke für ihr interesse sagt
es und wünsche ihnen alles gute
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter sturmtief auge
nähert sich von westen her und bringt
regen und viel wind mit das ist einiges
los morgen im tagesverlauf schauen wir
uns das ganze im detail an
von westen her wird in der zweiten
nachthälfte von westen her die bewölkung
dichter oder es gibt kräftigen regen und
teilweise wind aus süd die böen
erreichten durchaus schon 80 kilometer
pro stunde
stürmisch wird es und im südosten da
glock hat es auch bei null bis neun grad
und so sieht das ganze aus
ab den frühstunden vor allem geht es
dann von westen her los alles was hier
in rötlich eingefärbt ist sind bei 70
bis 100 kilometer pro stunde
und das ganze zieht sich im tagesverlauf
dann nach norden zurück morgen gibt es
dazu
schauer und blitz und donner können
dabei sein kräftiger regen und vor allem
in der nähe von schauern ist der wind
besonders kräftig im südosten da scheint
teilweise die sonne dort bis 20 grad
sonst an der küste um 10 grad ja und am
mittwoch im norden noch windig teils mit
schauern gewittern bei 7 bis 13 grad ab
donnerstag bleibt es ähnlich bei
weiteren schauern mit 9 bis 14 grad
damit ein schöner abend